the problem is that's German
jurisdiction and that's German police
this is technically Austria they will
not create your da we have to do
ourselves a bunch of people right now
we're about to board a free bus to the
border with Germany because none of the
trains are running today from Austria to
Germany
we're trying to send a message that we
are not just accrue few G's we are
engineers we are doctors we are lawyers
we are scientists so in our country and
say most of us they don't have a good or
a better education so for me I would
like to continue my study or to work
there
all I'm thinking about now is just to be
in German once you're in Germany
everything will be okay
so it's not the street and not once over
all right then you can go straight ahead
oh do they have to turn right you're
just gonna cross the street like this
yeah
all right we're crossing in math shuddhi
we're at the halfway point no not even
at the halfway point you say so what
have we will you read to oh there's a
lot of people here so yeah there's
hundreds of people over we hope we hope
we're not camping here I don't want you
happy I just want to continue walking we
just sell Molly in someone who can speak
English pretty much I'm sorry here's my
that does say it's German can they cross
now yeah we can we go now or we can I
feel hopeless I just want to place the
borders but like you see here it's
closed the other side of the ridge
there's so many refugees you can just
put them by bus because we don't have so
many buses just
a lot of chaos going on right now the
organizers in the volunteers are clear
the streets are clear that way and then
they'll open the German border people
just want to get through so they're
pushing a lot
this border was open a few hours ago to
everyone came comfortable
it just sealed it and they promised that
if there is Olga everyone will close
they were they were suffering like more
than us and both the guys first panel
see there like we had the worst trip
ever we almost drowned we were sleeping
in the rain I got my money stolen the
rafter on dysfunction I'm like which you
guys are still laughing they're like
what are we supposed to do everybody
else is set up their camps and put out
their sleeping bags and you guys are
yeah you know I get yesterday so what I
mean we could just just leave like this
just on the ground yeah just like yeah
of course what story I'm I'm winning and
you dance
that's right I was planning to get in
Germany with the new bitch that's why
it's you're pointing as brother earlier
thinking as a brand new shoes cuz they
want to enter Germany looking fucking
looking really good but I'm happy but
it's not Dame happening
I don't know or something